is college really worth it to these days
folks have been losing faith in higher
education as campuses transform into
breeding grounds of liberal
indoctrination according to Gallup
Americans confidence in higher education
has taken a nosedive plummeting to a
mere 36 percent but who needs that
four-year degree anyways companies are
increasingly dropping College
requirements for their jobs and focusing
more on real-world experiences okay so
the truth is and I think a lot of this
was instigated after the pandemic a lot
of companies have said you know what we
don't need a college education anymore
we're more interested in life experience
Harold look costs are high uh people are
trying to find the best jobs I think it
would we've said on the show the Senate
today held a hearing on the merger of a
proposed merger of the PGA and the Liv
it might behoove them to hold a hearing
on things we've talked about in terms of
why these costs keep going up and what
are these kids getting out of it private
sector companies do these assessments
every year if something worked last year
doesn't mean it's going to work next
year you figure out what you need to be
doing from your head count to your
strategy and sales to what you're doing
in terms of developing new Innovations
and new products we have to do the same
with education now I'm a believer that
AI is going to change the way we think
about what kids should be learning even
as we think about today the needs with
cops and teachers and family doctors and
so forth but AI is going to make it
where the this kind of Technology can do
some of the things that we want kids to
try to learn a day which I think is the
reason liberal arts education remains so
important some people who get caught up
in politics think liberal arts means
something political I think liberal arts
just helps you to that to teach us
critical thinking and problem solving if
you have that skill set you can do
anything and in fact you won't behave so
crazily uh if indeed you're taught uh
those Basics so I hope as much as we
rethink College we rethink how we teach
a liberal arts education at a younger
age Dana do you think the college is
really focus on critical thinking and
problem solving as as Harold just
suggested I think some do right and I
think it's some of the smaller schools
or a school like Purdue for example this
is a school that hasn't increased
tuition in many many years and they
figured out a way to make sure that
students are actually getting what they
need and also there's no reason that
somebody who's graduated from high
school should go into college and have
to take remedial English so K-12 is the
answer here because we want people to
have that opportunity right now
four-year college does guarantee well
right now
if you go to a four if you get a
four-year degree over the course of your
lifetime you are going to make a lot
more money than somebody who doesn't
have one that could change in the future
and I think a lot of parents want their
kids to go to a good school but problem
of supply and demand demand is down
because the quality of the supply is
really bad and it's over extended
however there are some good news on the
horizon uh Neil Ferguson and Barry Weiss
are part of a group that is starting a
new University it's called the
University of Austin check it out they
will have students the fall of 2024 they
are going to make it one where free
speech is allowed where you are getting
a classical education and the number of
applicants that they had 5 000
applicants for professors in the first
three months after they announced wow
and if you are somebody who wants your
kid to go to a place where you're going
to get a good education at a good price
check this out it's called the
University of Austin all right Greg the
the some some of the businesses that
hire people specifically for I.T say
that is the one area that you really
don't need a college degree right it's
kind of like it what was it before there
was it do you ever wonder what like what
that job was yeah or Radio Shack Radio
Shack yeah somebody you worked at Radio
Shack on the Xerox copy machine exactly
you would always come like twice a day
he had his big bag I I did I I hate to
say it but I got nothing out of college
I got nothing but accepted it allowed me
to age four years which was probably the
biggest most substantial thing that
happens is that you kind of your brain
grows a little you become less risky you
you start thinking about the few but I
didn't I mean I can't say there were
classes other than like fiction and
things like that what about the people
any any I mean a lot of people hated
everybody
I was a very lonely young boy back there
uh Harold uh you know but anyway I but I
don't want to be like Megan Rapinoe and
say hey you don't need it after I
already got it because you can't because
there are millions of people who should
go to college but it does need a
complete revamp but I was gonna bring
the University of Austin we need small
efficient low-cost colleges taught with
like enterprising High achieving
instructors that can then be zoomed out
so you could have you could have the
best math teacher in the country
teaching you math and just not have it
just not happens to be in the classroom
we're getting it's so funny to think
about it on any given day there's 10 000
people doing the same math uh problem
taught by the Same by 10 000 different
math people or Math teachers that's
idiotic you only need one person to do
that sorry but so I just think that we
need like realistic college for a
realistic Life Education on how to live
your life would be kind of nice it'd be
great for billionaires instead of going
to outer space to work on the Inner
Space you can steal that too
all right if you want to wrap it up I
was lucky enough that my parents paid
for my college if I couldn't have
afforded it I would have been
underwater 250 000 at 22 years old and
then I went into television and they
paid me twelve dollars an hour so I'd
still be in debt by then so I don't want
to discourage people from going to
college you learn how to live without
your parents and you learn how to
socialize and you learn a few things but
if you live in places maybe not the
Northeast
maybe not California coast there are a
lot of opportunities in the energy
sector in real estate where you can jump
right from your senior year and maybe
even make ninety thousand a hundred
thousand dollars right after college and
that's not something you want to just
turn your nose down can I mention one
other thing my brother-in-law teaches a
coding class it's a three-month course
that is done through the University of
Denver they contracted out so he teaches
us he has a new crop every three months
of people it's the butcher the Baker and
the Candlestick maker and these people
are making huge differences in their
lives going forward and able to work at
these tech companies making a lot of
money
hi everyone I'm Brian Kilmeade I want
you to do me a favor I want you to click
to subscribe to the Fox News YouTube
page this is the only way that I know
for sure that you're not going to miss
any great commentary any great news
bites any great interviews coming your
way on Fox you can get it all here on
YouTube so subscribe right now